direct sur la côte d'azur à cannes il
n'y a pas que les vedettes qui font leur
cinéma il ya aussi certaines voitures
renault a présenté là-bas sa twingo
marine twingo les maires patrice pollet
pour se faire remarquer pendant le
festival de cannes
rien de plus classe qu'un petit tour en
mer avec ma twingo une renault twingo de
base baptisée marine faut être barge une
idée dingue aussitôt réalisé un bon coup
de pub qui n'a pas de prix et qui de
toute façon n'est pas à vendre
deux moteurs mercury 250 chevaux vitesse
de pointe 50 km heure
on installe tout non la barre la
commande des moteurs est prête
clignotant tribord clignotants par heure
et bon vent cap au large l'avantagent
c'est ça pour faire ses courses chez les
meilleurs bijoux type pas de problème la
voiture possède les deux homologations
en route moussaillons et puis ce soir
pardonnez moi
nous sortons avec madame direction
cannes et ses starlettes n'est-il pas
vrai aussi que ma twingo est une venait
la dernière née de la régie renault qui
succédera à leers
jusqu'à présent on devrait se contenter
du match des images qui tous critiquent
désormais comme des hérétiques l'étude
comparative la voici à la baisse pour le
commentaire est plutôt semaine on ne
pouvait que la regarde se croyait en
plus
mais prudence de quelques automobiles et
rémission comparer le poggio la finition
par rapport à sa part a les qualités
techniques avec celles de nature des
premiers tests et les socios
très performant
merci
on
maintenant
les lieux
d
non
room room on va s'amuser premiers tours
de roues pour la 306 qui est la dernière
née de chez peugeot
elle sera commercialisée à partir du 18
février prochain on l'a dit sûre
confortable et surtout écolo écolo c'est
vrai parce que comme toutes les voitures
de conception moderne elle est largement
recyclables une 306 qui ressemble fort à
la 106 et à la 205 ces volontaires sur
ce nouveau numéro de psa les
commentaires de marie pierre farkas non
peugeot prénom 306 encore un chiffre
mais c'est la tradition à sochaux
mensurations 4 mètres de long pour 1 69
de larges lieux et dates de naissance
les astrologues auront le choix entre le
salon d'amsterdam le 2 février prochain
date de sa première sortie officielle ou
poissy le 18 jours de son arrivée dans
le commerce caractéristique c'est une
grosse 205 plus trapu et techniquement
plus avancé qu'une gtx
signe particulier elle est née en cinq
versions avec trois moteurs différents
tout on l'antiblocage de frein en option
nationalité française anglaise ou
espagnole selon keller a été conçu sur
les chaînes de poissy righton villaverde
bref elle est européenne
la preuve est là des phares blanc voilà
maintenant vous savez tout son identité
mais il faudra attendre de l'essayer
pour mieux sonder son âme
les particuliers ont certainement
alors je vous rassure les années modèles
cette oreille